this next optimization problem that i've
been sent seems seems fun i've actually
never seen this problem before
and and so i'm even more excited to do
it so it says a wire of length 100
centimeters is cut into two pieces so
let me draw this this wire
so that's our wire
it's going to be cut into two pieces let
me read the whole thing before i draw
anything one is bent to form a square
and the other is bent to form an
equilateral triangle
where should the cut be made
if a the sum of the two areas is to be a
minimum or maximum and it says allow the
possibility of no cut
fascinating so this is a hundred
centimeters long doesn't matter if it's
centimeters or meters or whatever
right so it's you know it's 100 long
it could be 100 miles long
that's a hundred and we're going to cut
it at some point
we'll cut it
there and let's just as a i shouldn't
have done it that because i was going to
use x and y but actually let's use a and
b since i made the cut look like an x so
let's say that that is a centimeters
from the left hand side of the wire and
then what is what's the distance from
the right hand side of the wire i could
call it b but even easier would just say
well if this is a then this is going to
be a hundred minus a
this is a hundred
minus a
and then there they say i'm going to
take one of the wires let me just say
the left hand wire
and i'm going to take it into and i'm
going to form a square which so not a
rectangle a square and then the other
wire is going to be 4 is going to form
an equilateral
triangle
okay so let's do it and actually i i can
already sense that it will be easier to
to manipulate
this one so i'm going to make the
equilateral triangle out of this side
and make the square out of this side
just because i have a sense that it'll
make the math a little easier so i'm
going to take this wire of length a and
form an equilateral triangle out of it
right so what is the triangle going to
look like it's going to look like and
i'm going to arbitrarily switch colors
now
so this is my equilateral triangle
all the sides are equal
and how long
are each of the sides going to be well
the whole perimeter is a
so each of these have to be a over 3
a over 3
a over 3. and then a over three
a over three
and then i also have a square with the
leftovers
and that hasn't
not that i was using the square tool
that says let me so i have it i should
use it
so i have a oh i don't want to do it
like that
there's my okay
so there's my square
and if the whole perimeter is 100 minus
a what is the length of each side it's
going to be this divided by 4 right
because all the sides are equal
so what's this
length divided by 4 100 divided by 8 by
4 100 minus 8 divided by 4 is 25 minus a
over 4 right so this side is 25
minus a over 4.
this side is 25 minus a over 4. and this
is the same thing 25 minus a over 4.
this is 25
minus a over 4.
and they want us to find what value of a
they want to find let's see they say the
sum of the two areas right they want to
say no what value of a minimizes
is that my phone no they want to know
what value of a
minimizes the sum of the two areas and
maximizes the sum of the two areas so
what are the sum of the two areas what's
the area of this triangle i always
forget the formula for the area of
equilateral triangles we'll have to kind
of derive it right now so what i do is i
always
draw something like that and then we
know that this length right here is a
over 6
that's a over 6 right just i'm just
doing the halfway point the whole thing
is a over 3. and if this is a 30 60 90
triangle right that's 30 this is 60 so
this is going to be square root of 3
times this so the height let me do that
here just so you don't you know what i'm
doing this is just some geometry
i'm drawing half the triangle
this would be a over 6
that's a over
and so this would be
square root
square root i always i want to make sure
that i'm doing my
right this is going to be the square
root of 3 times this so square root of 3
over
times a
so what's the area well the area of this
of this half triangle is
base times height times one-half
so the area of the whole triangle is
going to be this base times this height
so the area of the triangle
area of the triangle
is equal to
this base times that height
so it's area
area over 6 that's this times the height
times
square root of 3 over 6
area
and just so you remember you know area
of a triangle is one half base times
height so if we did one half base times
height we would get the area of this
triangle right but the area of the
entire triangle is two of these
triangles and so that's why i got rid of
the one half because it's two times one
half base times high so
hopefully that doesn't confuse you
that's just a little bit of geometry so
anyway the area of the triangle
the area of the triangle is equal to
is the square root of 3 over 36
a squared and what's the area of the
square that's easier that's just base
times height so
area of the square is equal to
minus a over four that's just base times
height
squared
and that is equal to this is 6
minus
2 times
so it's 20 let's see 25 over 4 minus 50
over 4
a right minus 50 over 4 a
50 over 4
a
plus
a squared
over 16. so that's the area of the
square but we want to know the the area
of the combined area
of both of them so what's the function
for the combined area so the combined
area and i'll do it in a bold color
the area of both of them i'll say area
combined that's equal the area of the
square plus the area of the triangle
so the area of the square
is
is let's see it's a
squared over 16
minus
over 4
a
plus
6 6 25 and we want to add the area of
the triangle
plus
square root of 3
over 36
a squared and we could you know that's
as a function of a we could put it put
it like that
so now we have to optimize it and we
want to find the minimum point and the
maximum point if if they exist let me
let me clear up some space
we've already the area of the square is
already implicitly there
i can actually clear up all of this here
and so what is
the derivative
a prime the combined
well actually hope you don't mind i'm
going to erase that too because i think
i'm going to run out of space and just
get all bunched up otherwise
that's not what i wanted to do
but you know what we're talking about
we've
we already have figured out the
area of the combined entities
and so now it's just pure calculus all
the geometry is done
so what is the
derivative
of the combined areas
as a function of a is equal to the
derivative of this expression
so it's 2 so it's what is this 2 times
16 2 over 1 2 over 16 so it's a over 8
so let me write this
well let's write it as a over 8
a over 8 let me draw a line here i don't
want things to get confused
a over 8
minus 50
over 4
this derivative 625 is just 0
plus
2 2 over
square root of 3
over 18
a
right and so we want to find the minimum
or the maximum values for this so
let's let's set this
equation is equal equal to zero
so we get
let me see what we can do let's let's
say the
we could add the a coefficients so we
have
1 8
plus square root of 3 over 18
a right i just added that to that minus
50 over 4 and we want to set this
derivative equal to 0. so let me switch
colors arbitrarily and so we get let me
add these two fractions
so 8 and 18 what's their common
denominator
so 8 and 9
8 and 9
is what is it is it 8 times 9 is it 72
and 1 over 8 is the same thing as 9 over
and so 18 goes into 72
four times
so that's
plus
four square roots of three
and all that times a
is equal to 50
over 4
and now we can multiply both sides times
the reciprocal of this coefficient
and we get
this isn't as maybe i made a careless
mistake but the numbers aren't coming
out too clean but maybe they're not
meant to
a
is equal to
over 4
times
over
9 plus 4 square roots of 3.
let's see if we can cancel anything out
this 4
becomes this becomes an 18
and so we get
a
is equal to
50 times 18
times 18 divided by 9 plus 4
square roots of
3.
now let's see
if that makes any kind of sense and i
think i'm going to have to get the
calculator for this one
calculator
okay
so
what should i do first let me let me
figure out what the denominator's value
is
so 3
square root
times 4
equals
plus
is equal to
15.928
so that a is equal to what's 50 times
5 it's 50
90 right 5 times 8 is 40 right so it's
over
15.9
so let me do that let me just
invert that
times
it equals 56.5
so a
is equal to 56.5
so at least we got a number that makes
sense i would it would have been
unfortunate if the point that we had to
cut this
wire was some number larger or you know
well you know god forbid we had a
negative number there but we actually
got a positive number and it's a number
between 0 and 100. so we are probably
right so but the question is
is this a minimum value or is this a
maximum value and to figure that out
well let's just see if we're concave
upwards or downwards at this point
so let's let's think about it so let's
take the second derivative
of our combined area function
so this is our combined this was our
combined area function
right we set it equal to zero so let's
take the second derivative of that
well that just equals the derivative of
this it equals
1 8
plus square root of 3 over 18
well times a but well that just so it's
just the coefficient and then that goes
to 0. so that equals
a
prime prime as a function of a the
combined areas as a function of a is
just a constant number and it is a
positive constant number so what does
that tell us given that that is a
positive constant number that tells us
that at any value of a at any value of a
the second derivative is positive
the second derivative is positive tells
us that we are
concave upwards
really over the whole function
the whole this whole combined area
function we're concave upwards and
concave upward and how do we know that
well if the second derivative is
positive the slope is always increasing
right
and that tells us that any value where
we where the where the slope is 0 which
was this one
is actually a minimum point
is actually a minimum point so a is
equal to 56.5 so if we cut it at 56.5
we are actually at a minimum point so
how would we maximize the combined
values
well maybe here we have to just take one
of the boundary conditions so maybe we
could set a is equal to 0
or we could set a is equal to 100 and
figure out what the values are and one
of those have to be our maximum value
so what happens when a is equal to 0. so
what is
so this was our function to begin with
what is our combined area function if a
is zero well this is zero this is zero
that is zero so it equals 625
625 and what is that what does that
translate into that's the case where the
entire wire is used to make a square and
none of the wire is used to make a
triangle in that situation our combined
area and all the areas coming from the
square would be 625.
well what happens when a is equal to
a hundred when a is equal to a hundred
when air
is equal to a hundred
well then
all of the if if this if this is equal
to 100 then the square the area of the
square is zero so we can actually even
ignore these terms we actually know that
this will evaluate to zero because we
are committing no wire to the square and
so what is the area of the triangle well
this was this term right here was the
area of the triangle
so it
it equaled square root of 3 over 36
times
squared
so what is that
so let's see if we can do that
so 3
square root
divided by
36 is equal to and then 100 squared is
10 000 right so times
1 10 one two three
four hundred and eighty one
let's go 481. so what do we know we know
that if we cut it exactly at 56.5 and
it's actually there's some even there's
a little bit more precision that i kind
of didn't pay attention to but if we cut
it at roughly 56.5 the combined area
actually we haven't even figured out
where that combined area is but we know
it's a minimum point because we're
concave upward at that point and as a
fun exercise for you you might want to
plug it into your calculator and figure
out what the actual areas of that point
and realize that it is the low point so
that is the minimum value that's how we
minimize the area of the square and the
triangle
now if we committed all the wire to the
square we get an area of 625 and all of
it comes to the square if we if we cut
it so that if we cut it so that you know
we cut it here so all of the wire is
used to make the triangle we get an area
of 481 so the maximum value is when a is
equal to 0
and our combined area 625 because we're
doing a square with the with the whole
wire and the minimum value is when we
actually cut it
right there at
56.5 so where we commit 56.5
to the triangle
and we commit
you know the remainder so what is that
43.5 to the square
that's when we minimize it that was a
frankly a fascinating problem and i hope
i got the problem right and even if i
made a careless mistake i think you
understand how to do the problem i will
see you in the next video